sohn ist bei uns bdi-präsident lange bei
thyssenkrupp ehemalige siemens-vorstand
airbus vom glauben sie glaubt ein mann
der wirtschaft wie sie an ein baldiges
ende dieses krieges und das danach in
der wirtschaft alles mal wieder so war
es also zu der dauer der sache ich das
will ich nicht spekulieren da gibt es
menschen die viel kompetenter sind als
ich aber es wird nicht mehr so sein wie
vorher das ist nicht denkbar wie eine
wiederannäherung zwischen der
weltgemeinschaft und russland als nation
dem russischen volk dosieren kann
ehrlich gesagt fällt noch heute die
fantasie aber das wird lange dauern bis
diese narben verheilt den bands
überhaupt möglich ist
sie haben auch angekündigt und gesagt
dass russland gerade die
geschäftsordnung des globalen
miteinanders verändert andere
wirtschaftswissenschaftler sprechen von
einem neuen eisernen vorhang und acht
auch diese diese
globalisierung ein ende gefunden hat und
wir im grunde eine neue trennung der
welt haben ist das so aber wir haben
ganz sicher eine neue situation denn bei
allen systemen differenzen bei aller
rivalität gab es an gewissen
grundkonsens wie man miteinander umgeht
und den hat wladimir putin aufgekündigt
und deswegen haben wir ja eine ganz neue
situation mit der wir umgehen müssen man
zieht nicht selber vor acht wochen noch
für unmöglich gehalten hat luisa
neubauer ist bei uns von freitags fünf
user mitbegründerin dieser bewegung
klimaaktivisten sehen in den sanktionen
vielleicht von neubauer jetzt auch eine
chance also wir liefern waffen und wir
können im grunde nur mit sanktionen
reagieren sind diese harten sanktionen
in ihren augen auch eine chance in den
augen mancher aktivisten
also wir sind in einem angriffskrieg das
leid was wir personal bei uns miterleben
was was die ukrainerin olena aushalten
müssen da würde ich erst mal überhaupt
nicht von irgendeiner chance für
irgendwen sprechen dass es erst mal
dramatisch und tragisch und ich kenne
niemanden denen das kalt lässt mich ja
auch nicht logischerweise
und was wir sehen ist dass es die
situation auch kommen konnte weil man
was ich so abhängig gemacht hat von
putins fossilen energien also wir sind
so erpressbar wir sind so abhängig weil
man immer weiter wider besseren wissens
auch während der schon er sonst was auf
der krim angerichtet hat weiter
investiert war weiter nordwind 2 gebaut
hat und so weiter und so fort und was
wir jetzt sehen als das eben diese
fossile abhängigkeit keine zukunft hat
egal in welche richtung und es ist ein
moment um in dem man sich entscheiden
muss dort von wirklich radikale abkehr
zu nehmen und tatsächlich was zu machen
was demokratisch und frei und
klimafreundlich ist wie nichts anderes
nämlich eine richtig radikale
energiewende
das hat für mich wenig schneller kommt
glaubt die muss jetzt schneller kommen
das ist nicht selbstverständlich ich
würde es nicht als chance bezeichnet
sondern als sehr logische und notwendige
konsequenz aus situationen vor uns robin
alexander ist bei uns der vertretende
chefredakteur der welt alexander
panzerfäuste geliefert durch die
deutschen nord stream zwei beendet in
windeseile 100 milliarden zur verfügung
gestellt für die deutsche bundeswehr das
sind aus deutscher sicht alles quasi 100
schritte für unsere verbündeten sind sie
klein und für die ukraine zu klein die
100 milliarden haben mit der ukraine und
nichts zu tun er stimmt also dass wir
jetzt sagen wir möchten eine bundeswehr
haben die funktioniert hilft in der
ukraine niemandem das ist etwas das
grüne tun können wir lassen nord stream
zwei floors ja noch nie gas das war ja
die nächste schlinge die puten gelichtet
und die ukraine haben wirklich auf den
fußmatten des deutschen
regierungsviertels gewinn seit last
dasein seid ihr wahnsinnig und zwar
nicht acht wochen sondern seit jahren
und die deutschen lieferungen sind
gekommen als der krieg begonnen hat also
die erfolge die die experten gerade
erläutert hat kommen von waffen der
kanadier der amerikaner der briten mit
denen die trainiert haben also wenn die
ukraine sich auf uns verlassen hätte
hätte putin wahrscheinlich schon
gewonnen wir reden auch und reden nicht
zum ersten mal über die historischen
fehler die gemacht worden sind da darf
man sich jetzt spd und cdu/csu natürlich
munter die bälle zu was würden sie sagen
was ist ihre einschätzung wen die größte
schuld an dieser situation trifft sowohl
in bezug auf unsere
verteidigungsfähigkeit also auch die
abhängigkeit ich würde gerne die
kategorie schuld der kirche überlassen
aber sondern von historischer
verantwortung spricht dann hat
deutschland eine historische
verantwortung weil putin hat das was er
jetzt tut schon einmal getan zum
beispiel in syrien und wir haben
trotzdem weiter mit ihm geschäfte
gemacht gasgeschäfte aber auch anderes
und er dachte doch augenscheinlich dass
er weitermachen kann also seine
fehlkalkulation bestand ja darin dass
wir es diesmal anders machen gott sei
dank aber das wird diese man die
illusion gegeben haben wir wären als
gesellschaft so käuflich zu schwach das
ist doch etwas was wir alle zusammen
bedenken müssen oder muss ich an meine
eigene nase packen als journalist dass
wir also wie als welt haben kritisiert
aber wenn man das nicht zum
entscheidenden thema gemacht das war ein
fehler aber auch die politik von frau
merkel die politik von herrn steinmeier
war augenscheinlich durch historisch
falsch und das müssen wir aufarbeiten
als gesellschaft wir sind jetzt das tun
wir gemeinsam mit christine lambrecht
wir sind in new york verbunden mit dem
bundesverteidigungsministerium die ihren
antrittsbesuch in den usa macht auch
gerade von den vereinten nationen kommt
von lamprecht erstmal einen guten tag zu
ihnen
die schalte steht hoffentlich
die schalter steht hoffentlich wie
können sie hier gut verstehen die
amerikaner sind den deutschen dankbar
für diese historische bewegung die wir
da vollzogen haben auch in bezug auf
waffenlieferungen und
ausweiten unseres verteidigungsetats
oder wünschen sich die amerikanischen
kollegen mehr von ihnen mehr von
deutschland
also was ich hier gehört habe bei meinen
gesprächen in den letzten tagen egal ob
mit senatoren
abgeordneten oder auch meinen kollegen
lloyd austin ist dass das was
deutschland leistet hoch geschätzt wird
das betrifft zum einen die
waffenlieferungen in die ukraine und
dass sie ihr da unsere position auch
verändert haben nachdem der brutale
angriffskrieg gestartet ist aber auch
dass wir ein deutliches signal senden
durch die 100 milliarden investitionen
in die bundeswehr dass wir sagen wir
sind ein verlässlicher partner auch in
zukunft das sind wir schon wir haben
sehr schnell die
verbündeten an der ostflanke unterstützt
durch truppen größeren an in littau und
durch er politik in rumänien und jetzt
verstärken wir auch in der slowakei aber
in zukunft sind wir noch eher in der
lage schnell zu reagieren uns
einzubringen sowohl in die nato als auch
und die sicherheitspolitik der
europäischen union das leider wichtiges
zeichen und wird auch genauso wie sehen
von den amerikanischen verbündeten bis
gestern wollten sie frau lamprecht über
waffenlieferungen vielleicht bleiben wir
bei denen erst mal nicht reden und zwar
aus sicherheitsgründen nicht reden jetzt
möchten sie das offensichtlich es ist ja
bekannt geworden dass mit über 200
produkten eine größere lieferung an
warten zur verfügung gestellt werden
sollen tun sie das weil man jetzt
endlich eine größenordnung erreicht die
sich die ukraine schon immer gewünscht
haben oder warum
ich werde auch in zukunft nicht über
waffenlieferungen sprechen bäderbahn
wohin und wie viel und was geliefert
wird weil es ist ein sicherheitsrisiko
mir geht es darum dass das was wir
liefern sowohl an waffen als auch ein
anderes bild dann auch tatsächlich da
ankommt wo es dringend gebraucht wird
und das ist die ukraine und dem moment
wo ich öffentlich darüber sprechen
werden diese transporte zur zielscheibe
und da sitzen fahrrad drin die werden
begleitet von feldjägern oder sind alles
menschen und die werde ich nicht in
gefahr bringen dadurch dass ich so etwas
ankündigen
und ich glaube auch nicht dass es
militärisch strategisch sinnvoll ist
wenn wir alle über solche lieferungen
sprechen das gute dass russland genau
weiß über welche waffen die ukraine
verfügt und über welche auch nicht und
deswegen ist es gut und richtig dass wir
uns in der bundesregierung darauf
verständigt haben dass wir das geheim
einstufen wir liefern wir liefern
konsequent größenordnung von über 80
millionen euro ist bisher aus
deutschland geliefert worden sowohl
durch abgabe aus der bundeswehr jetzt
auch durch ankauf das ist ganz wichtig
dass wir alle möglichkeiten nutzen um
die ukraine zu stützen
mit berichten darüber sondern mit
konkreten leistungen andere länder
verhalten sich da anders sieht und gehen
sehr wohl davon aus dass man einiges
transparenz halten kann und sogar muss
um eben auch eine welt öffentlichkeit
darüber zu informieren
robin alexander hatten sie die frage
ihre kollegen und sie haben recherchiert
dass die ukraine selbst in deutschland
eingekauft hat und zwar in größenordnung
selbst angekauft hat für eigenes geld zu
sagen weil diese lieferungen aus standen
er ist damit bewegung in die sache
gekommen glauben sie und zusätzlich
bewegung ja unbedingt ich kann das gar
nicht nachvollziehen richter sagt dass
alles so zufrieden werden wenn man die
ukraine fragt sie gar nicht zufrieden
und die haben nach den amerikanern
gefragt
entschuldigung aber und die ukraine
haben tatsächlich selber eingekauft weil
dann liegt die federführung für die
genehmigung nicht beim ministerium von
frau lamprecht sondern beim
wirtschaftsministerium und das ging sehr
viel schneller als das bei vollem recht
gegangen ist und die ukraine waren auch
bemüht dass die deutsche öffentlichkeit
davon erfährt haben sie frau lamprecht
eine erklärung dafür ist es die richtige
warum diese neuen waffenkäufe schneller
zu genehmigen waren durch den
bundeswirtschaftsminister
als lieferungen aus dem altbestand der
bundeswehr durch sie ist das eine
erklärung
nein ganz bestimmt nicht und ich bin in
ständigem austausch zu meinem
ukrainischen kollegen gerade gestern
wieder mit ihm telefoniert und die
entscheidung die ich ihm da mitteilen
konnte da geht es um eine ent abgabe ein
verbleibs abgabe die hat ihn sehr
erfreut also von daher eher und ich wir
sind in einem sehr konstruktiven und vor
allen dingen in einem kontinuierlichen
austausch
da wird regelmäßig abgeklärt was braucht
ihr was haben wir was können wir abgeben
denn ich habe ja auch die verantwortung
dafür zu sorgen dass die bundeswehr nur
das abgibt was sie in der lage ist damit
sie weiterhin auch gewährleisten kann
dass sie den auftrag der landes- und
bündnisverteidigung nachkommen kann dass
sie die einsatzbereitschaft auch
gewährleisten kann aber wenn das nicht
der fall ist dann gehen auch wir den weg
des ankaufs und wie gesagt größenordnung
von über 80 millionen in der letzte in
dieser zeit ist es bis jetzt schon
erfolgter legen es kann eigentlich nicht
darum zu verzögern um himmels willen wir
wollen die die ukraine da unterstützen
mit den möglichkeiten die wir haben und
das geschieht kontinuierlich aber eben
nicht in der presse wladimir klitschko
ist heute schon zu zitieren nun hat sich
tatsächlich auch eine kollegin von ihnen
nämlich annalena baerbock in dieser
woche ja beklagt uns veröffentlichte
klagt darüber dass sich der ukrainische
aussenminister mehr hilfe wünscht
schauen wir mir geht das auch bis an die
nieren wenn ich den anruf bekommen sage
von meinem ukrainischen außenminister
kollegen wo sind die waffen natürlich
telefonieren wir hinterher schauen wo
hat es gehakt so also da beklagt sich
die außenministerin dass sie herrn kohl
eber sorgen muss dass sie waffen eben
nun gefunden aufgefunden und auch
geliefert wurden in diesem konkreten
fall offensichtlich scheint es bei ihnen
dazu hacken im verteidigungsministerium
warum so spät und warum so wenig
wir haben uns entschieden in der
bundesregierung in der bundesregierung
dass wir die gesamten lieferungen von
waffen von ausstattung von weiteren
waren dass wir die abstimmung dass wir
die alles über den bundessicherheitsrat
laufen lassen das geht dann auch sehr
schnell weil das nicht im präsenz
stattfinden muss das läuft telefonisch
ab deswegen ist das eine abgestimmte
position innerhalb der bundesregierung
und keine einzel entscheidung des
verteidigungsministeriums oder auch des
wirtschaftsministeriums weil wir alle da
gemeinsam an einem strang ziehen aber
ich kann natürlich die ungeduld der
ukraine in dieser situation in der sie
sich befinden die kann ich voll und ganz
nachvollziehen ja selbstverständlich
er wünscht man sich da immer mehr immer
schneller lieferungen aber wir haben 1 1
ein verfahren worauf wir uns verständigt
haben und es ist die gesamte
bundesregierung dass es nicht die
verteidigungsministerin dass es nicht
der wirtschaftsminister sonders sind wir
gemeinsam und genauso gehen wir auch vor
kontinuierlich seit sie nochmals 80
millionen sind wir ja schon dieser zum
dritten mal und weise an die ukraine
geliefert haben ja ja sag ich das ja
nicht ganz so bekannt wie das ist eine
dieser dimension hat also lenski wünscht
sich weiter dass der bundeskanzler
mauern einreißen möge wladimir klitschko
ist heute in der stadt um neue
waffenlieferungen zu bitten herr
kiesewetter sie führen nun die
opposition an uns interessiert dennoch
natürlich was sie sagen können wir mehr
ist es berechtigt darauf zu verweisen
dass wir auch an die sicherheit der
bundeswehr und unserer ausrüstung denken
müssen sind diese prozesse zu recht so
langwierig was zunächst unterstützen wir
den paradigmenwechsel den die
bundesregierung gemacht hat dass viele
forderungen viele forderungen die wir
die wir ja selber nicht durchsetzen
konnten werden jetzt endlich gemacht
dennoch es geht zu langsam und was mir
fehlt ist eine klare information unserer
bevölkerung unsere bevölkerung muss
darauf vorbereitet werden dass diese
schwierige sicherheitslage einen preis
hat das eine sind die waffenlieferung
das anderes die aufnahme von
flüchtlingen ich wünsche mir dass die
verteidigungsministerin den schwung
nutzen und die beschaffung innerhalb der
bundeswehr beschleunigt da helfen die
gelder zunächst nichts da muss man eine
organisationsreform machen und das dann
die gelder nicht mit der gießkanne
ausgegeben werden sondern sehr sinnvoll
abgestuft in einem vernünftigen
vergleich zu diesen 115 bundeswehr
ausstattung hilft ja jetzt also diese
zukünftige außerdem gilt ja jetzt gerade
in dieser situation eigentlich gar nicht
vielleicht noch mal eine frage
zwischendurch an frau polieren nato
insider sagen und auch das kann man eben
lesen und erfährt dass die ukraine
massiv unterstützt wird der sprechen
kollegen sogar davon dass die ukraine
geflutet wird mit waffen ist der beitrag
der deutschen denn da überhaupt so
nennenswert und kann der wirklich mehr
beitragen also vielleicht setze ich die
zahlen mal ein bisschen ins st lambrecht
hat von 80 millionen gesprochen die die
deutschen investiert haben die esten
geben an 220 millionen investiert zu
haben die amerikaner geben an 800
millionen investiert zu haben vielleicht
setzt dass das mit den deutschen beitrag
in die perspektive ich erkenne an es gab
einen tabubruch in deutschland ich bin
froh dass wir uns überhaupt dazu
durchringen konnten waffen zu liefern
aber zumindest auch von der
kommunikativen seite von dich ist nicht
alles optimal gelaufen erst gab es die
aussage wir finden keine weiteren waffen
mehr wir sind an unsere grenzen gekommen
dann gab es doch wieder waffen und ich
hätte mir deutlich ein deutlich
beherztes vorgehen von deutschland
durchaus gewünscht und ich glaube wir
können mehr machen gerade wenn man das
vergleich zum beispiel mit island oder
den vereinigten staaten hier nochmal
robin alexander zu den dingen die sie
auch recherchiert haben was kann da
zukünftig schneller gehen und was wird
an waffen noch kommen auch weil der
bundeskanzler selbst hier ankündigt das
ist bei dieser massiven unterstützung
für die ukraine bleiben soll erstmal
möchte ich gerne eine nebelkerze
aufheben die frau lambrich wiederholt
geworfen hat wenn wir als journalisten
oder auch parlamentarier uns erkundigen
ob die bundeswehr oder die industrie
waffen liefert dann wollen wir doch
nicht die wege beschreiben in die in die
ukraine gebracht werden wir sind doch
nicht verrückt und wir werden das auch
nicht tun bevor das da ist wissen doch
nicht verrückt es geht uns darum den
umfang zu kommen das ist etwas ganz
anderes und ich finde das empörend dass
diese nebelkerzen kommunikation gemacht
wird weil die rückt und seine position
als wären wir verantwortungslos das sind
wir nicht und was ist passiert als es
diese zeitenwende gab vorher wurde er
gar nicht geliefert außer 5000 helme sei
hier nicht in krisen gewinner und dann
wurden stinger raketen geliefert und
panzerfäuste und dann hieß es wir
sprechen nicht mehr drüber aber
wochenlang ist gar nichts passiert da
sind essensrationen geliefert worden
auch wichtig und dinge fürs lazarett und
so weiter und dann hat frau lambrecht
gesagt die arsenale der bundeswehr sind
erschöpft ich zitiere und danach wurden
plötzlich wieder panzerfäuste gefunden
wir hatten in der welt am sonntag eine
recherche dass die industrie sehr
frühzeitig angeboten hat bestände
nachzufüllen also wenn die bundeswehr
etwas abgibt was wir gar nicht brauchen
weil wir gottlob nicht im krieg sind
kann die industrie vielleicht dass in
wenigen minuten wenigen monat nach
liefern so und darüber transparent als
bundesregierung zu kommunizieren ist
doch ein recht dass die öffentlichkeit
hat und ich verstehe überhaupt nicht
dass diese fragen immer so skandalisiert
werden von lamprecht also die sachliche
frage zunächst die nach dem fakt wäre es
denn möglich dass man aus den beständen
der bundeswehr liefert um dann die
industrie nach liefern zu lassen weil
wir dafür tatsächlich noch fünf oder
sechs monate zeit hätten anders als die
ukraine
genau den weg gehen wir wir gehen den
weg dass wir nach und nach aus unseren
beständen liefern so wie wir aber auch
wiederum an kaufen können damit die
bestände aufgefüllt werden das ist genau
der weg und deswegen ist es auch zu
diesen lieferungen gekommen obwohl wir
in einer schwierigen situation sind was
unsere eigenen bestände bedeutet aber
genau den weg gehen wir aber zu glauben
dass wir in einer völlig sicheren
situation sondern das uns ja in den
nächsten monaten überhaupt nichts
passieren kann
die kann ich so nicht bestätigen und ich
habe die verantwortung dass jederzeit
die landes- und die bündnisverteidigung
gewährleistet werden kann und nicht erst
in fünf monaten aber das ist ja zu
dreschen zügig wir haben alles das was
wir was wir was wir liefern so wie es
möglich ist an zu kaufen um dann nach
und nach zu liefern okay dennoch ist es
ja ein kluges argument zu sagen es geht
gar nicht darum irgendjemanden zu
gefährden sondern es geht darum zu
verstehen in welchem umfang die
deutschen tatsächlich behilflich sind
und danach werden sie regelmäßig gefragt
und das sagen andere nato verbündete
länder eben auch
es sagen ganz viele unserer verbündeten
überhaupt nichts über das was sie
liefern über das was sie leisten
das ist ihre entscheidungen die kann ich
dann auch nachvollziehen aber es ist so
dass die meisten der nato ländern die
liefern dieses nicht öffentlich machen
und ich habe sehr wohl solche anfragen
gehabt wann wird was geliefert wann geht
der transport raus also es ist nicht so
dass solche anfragen nicht an uns
herangetragen werden und da bitte ich um
verständnis das ist eine gefährdung wenn
man darüber redet jetzt wird das und das
geliefert dann bedeutet das dass dieser
transport gefährdet ist der
bundesregierung darauf verständigt dass
wir die größenordnung veröffentlichen
die größenordnung in der wir liefern
aber eben nicht was das ist geheim
geheim eingestuft und das ist die
entscheidung der bundesregierung dafür
zu sorgen dass zum einen die lieferung
nicht gefährdet werden und auch das
militärisch nachvollziehbar eben auch
nicht erkennbar ist über was verfügt die
ukraine aus unseren beständen und über
was auch nicht formulieren jetzt wird ja
sogar darüber geredet dass die ukraine
andere waffen brauchen eben weil putin
offenbar seine strategie verändert und
weil er eben nicht mehr in die städte
und in die region hinein geht sondern
aus einer entfernung von 20 30
kilometern die städte bombardiert und es
andere waffen braucht also das weiß man
ja auch insofern wer liefert jetzt
welche waffen damit die ukraine sich
auch morgen und übermorgen verteidigen
können also ich verstehe sehr gut dass
die nato im bei einigen waffen zögerlich
war wir hatten ja eine große diskussion
über die mic die die nichts geliefert
worden sind aus sorge dass einmal
vielleicht das für die ukraine gar nicht
so viel helfen würde aber eben auch aus
sorge dass man gewisse grenzen nicht
überschreiten möchte die nato zieht ja
eine sehr klare rote linie und definiert
für sich dass sie nicht aktive
kriegspartei werden möchte deswegen auch
die absage an eine flugverbotszone
dennoch glaube ich dass es ist eine sehr
feine linie aber ich glaube dass wir uns
darüber bewusst sein müssen dass
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine die
lebenslinie der ukraine sind die
tatsache dass putin überhaupt ein
kleines bisschen abgerückt ist von
seinen ursprünglichen forderungen ist
allein nur der tatsache geschuldet dass
die ukraine so erfolgreich kämpft die
ukraine kämpft so erfolgreich weil sie
die waffen bekommen und sie ist darauf
angewiesen dass wir sie weiter
unterstützen wir müssen gucken was wir
liefern können aber es ist durchaus
einiges möglich was wir bislang noch
nicht tun ich gebe frau lambrecht
tatsächlich recht man muss nicht ganz
transparent sein in dem was man liefert
aber
man kann gerade was
luftabwehr betrifft könnte man mehr mehr
tun auch luftabwehrsysteme die wir
offensichtlich zur verfügung stellen
herr kiesewetter hat schon angedeutet
wir kommen zu den 100 milliarden und dem
was wir in der bundeswehr ausgeben
werden oder ausgeben wollen flugzeuge
aus amerika sind angesprochen es ist
ergo 3 angesprochen diese besondere
raketenabwehrschirm drohnen aus israel
sind im gespräch
sind diese maßnahmen jetzt schon zügig
in die wege zu leiten oder reden wir
auch da wieder über drei vier und fünf
jahre
in denen wir eben auf unsere sicherheit
da immer noch nicht bauen können ich
rate da wirklich ganz nüchtern zu sein
und auch strategisch langsam wir müssen
erst mal schauen welche bedrohungen
haben wir offensichtlich sind das
mittelstreckenraketen die in kaliningrad
sind und über schnelle flugkörper die
auch aus russland zu uns fliegen können
dieses eur 3 system kann mittelstrecken
raketen abfangen aber nach aber nicht
die hyperschall deswegen brauchen wir
ein konzept das in der nato eingebunden
ist ich denke dass zu erarbeiten ist in
einem halben jahr zu machen dass zu
erproben und auszubilden dass wir
sprechen von mindestens zwei jahren wir
sind froh lamprecht bei der frage in die
usa sind sie jetzt vielleicht auch
gegangen um nach diesen waffen zu fragen
die wir dann kaufen wollen unter anderem
eben auch die f35 kauft man das jetzt
auf pump dieses sondervermögen gibt's ja
noch nicht diese 100 mio
ja aber solche solche ankauf verfahren
solche beschaffungsverfahren sind auch
sehr langwierige wir haben die aufgabe
den tornado abzulösen tornado wird nur
noch bis 2030 die nukleare teilhabe
sichern können und deswegen gilt es
darum frühzeitig also jetzt diese
entscheidung zu treffen so richtig
vorzeitig ist das gar nicht das hätte
eigentlich schon im letzten jahr
mindestens erfolgen sollen aber jetzt
ist es geschehen wir haben uns für die
nachfolge entschieden 11 35 und deswegen
ja geht es natürlich auch dann darum
jetzt zügig dafür zu sorgen und wenn ich
über zügig rede dann reden wir hier über
jahre aber wir müssen gewährleisten bis
2030 muss dieser beschaffung
abgeschlossen sein bis 2030
abgeschlossen sein es ist eine
parlamentariergruppe nach israel
gefahren um sich dieses r 3 system
anzuschauen der bundeskanzler hatte auch
angedeutet dass das etwas ist was wir
dringend brauchen aber eben nicht nur
für uns sondern es wäre dann tatsächlich
etwas was wir auch polen und dem
baltikum dann anbieten können als schutz
es ist tatsächlich so wie herr
kiesewetter beschrieben hat wir
identifizieren gerade welche bedrohungen
welchen bedrohungen sehen wir uns denn
aktuell ausgesetzt und aufgrund dieser
sind auf diese einschätzung da
entscheiden wir dann welche
beschaffungen brauchen wir das ist der
richtige weg und nicht listen jetzt
abzuarbeiten die vielleicht mal 2009 10
für die bundeswehr vorgesehen war das
ist der weg und da bin ich im
kontinuierlichen austausch auch mit dem
bundeskanzler und vor allen dingen auch
mit unseren nato partnern dann ist es
wichtig dass wir in der nato auch
geschlossen aufgestellt sind und dass
wir vor allen dingen unseren verbündeten
an der ostflanke die ja diese
bedrohungslage viel mehr erfahren als
wir dass wir da auch sicherstellen
können wir stehen zusammen und wir haben
dann auch die entsprechende ausstattung
das ist momentan die situation in der
wir sehr geschlossen agieren und uns
gemeinsam aufstellen und nicht jeder
einzelne das ist der richtige weg
nochmal frage an robin alexander 75
milliarden wird in der zukunft unserer
verteidigungsetat betragen damit wären
wir die größten oder kräftigsten
zusammen mit den kräftigsten
verteidigungsetat innerhalb europas wir
hatten 50 bis 55 milliarden das war auch
nicht wenig geld wann und wie wird sich
substanziell an der arbeit und an der
beschaffung etwas ändern das ist eine
prophetische frage die mich total
überfordert ich bin auch immer noch
beeindruckt
ich bin auch immer noch beeindruckt von
dem argument von lamprecht dass wir wenn
wir jetzt waffen weiter an die ukraine
geben würden die gefahr hätten unsere
eigene sicherheit zu entblößen nach der
ansage von olaf scholz zur zeitenwende
sind es die raketen und panzerfäusten
500.000 geliefert worden und das nächste
material waren raketen der nationalen
volksarmee die auf einem bundeswehr
hofgarten und man suchte einen anbieter
mit dem man sie konkret entsorgen kann
und danach wie gesagt die arsenale sind
erschöpft die lage der bundeswehr wäre
dann dann wäre es wirklich bitter das
kann nicht sein
und ich finde bei diesen beträgen ist
immer so bitter man kann sich ja immer
vorstellen was wäre dann wenn man damit
andere sachen kaufen könnte also wie
viele schulen wie für kindergarten wie
viel was immer aber ich weiß dass wir
das brauchen ich sehe ja was putin tut
und ich hoffe dass das jetzt endlich
organisiert wird weil das ist ein thema
mit dem die politik sich schon zehn
jahre um schlicht noch mal zurück zu
frau lamprecht die frage nach dem was
wir dahin geschickt haben
ist das tatsächlich so also die
verschimmelten kisten haben wir alle zur
kenntnis genommen dann wurde aber gesagt
aus dem verteidigungsministerium wenn
ich recht informiert bin das ja nur die
kisten schimmlig waren und nicht die
waffen liegen waren ist das ein argument
also sie können sich sicher sein und
auch insbesondere die ukraine dass alles
das was wir liefern auch tatsächlich
einsatzfähig ist das wird genau geprüft
und sichergestellt und das ist auch
genau so erfolgt ich kann die versuche
verstehen jetzt nochmal hier auch in
diesem gespräch mich dazu zu bringen zu
sagen was denn darüber hinaus noch
geliefert wurde aber alleine das
zusammenzählen von tausend dinge oder
von den des trailers wird macht ja schon
relativ
leicht deutlich dass es dann nicht die
80 millionen ergeben würde also von
daher kann man erkennen dass deutlich
mehr geliefert wurde aber ich werde
jetzt nicht in dieser sendung genau das
machen was wir gerade nicht wollen
nämlich offenlegen was geliefert wurde
die abgeordneten haben die möglichkeit
das einzusehen in der geheimschutzstelle
aber nochmal das würde ja nicht 80
millionen bedeuten aber wir schauen
jedes mal genau was bedeutet die abgabe
davon für unsere einsatzbereitschaft
wenn ich beispielsweise die truppen
verstärkt habe in littau und mit
mehreren hundert soldatinnen und
soldaten dann hat das bedeutet dass
dafür auch die ausrüstung mitgegeben
werden musste natürlich und dann bin ich
in der situation dass ich nicht irgendwo
ein großlager habe wo ich mich bedienen
kann sollte sich an allen standorten in
deutschland zusammentragen muss damit
die soldatinnen und soldaten
entsprechend auch ausgestattet dort
hingehen können in der situation
befinden wir deswegen geht es auch bei
diesen 100 mio die wir jetzt brauchen
wir dringend brauchen nicht darum
aufzurüsten wir ja auch teilweise und
der stellt wird alles getan dass wir
endlich die ausrüstung haben die wir
brauchen und so wurde in der nato aber
auch für unsere landesverteidigung
umfassend aufgestellt zu sein und genau
solche situationen nicht sind dass man
von überall aus gesamtschaden mal einige
hundert soldatinnen soldaten
auszustatten heraus von wird uns helfen
bei der frage 100 milliarden das ist ein
ordentlicher betrag in der zukunft für
die bundeswehr frau ministerin geht eben
offensichtlich da jetzt auch in amerika
und in anderen ländern shoppen deutsche
arbeitsplätze werden dadurch nicht
besonders entstehen oder ich glaube dass
es auch nicht die erste priorität muss
mich viel mehr irritiert sind die zeit
stritten also was ist denn zügig
was wir lernen ist wir müssen jetzt
mauern einreißen paradigmen einreißen
vielleicht können wir auch zügiger
beschaffung machen dadurch dass wir
waffensysteme kaufen die bei unseren
verbündeten im betrieb sind also die f35
ist ja nicht ein zukunfts flugzeug
sondern andere nato luftstreitkräfte
fliegen damit wieso das so lange dauern
muss ist mir nicht einsichtig die
direktlieferung von deutschen in
unternehmen der verteidigungsindustrie
nach in die ukraine hat das
sicherheitskabinett genehmigt also wir
sind ja dabei transparent lieber nur
sein können aber allein die tatsache
dass das so schnell ging die gibt mir zu
denken dass es vielleicht gar nicht an
den lieferanten liegt sondern dann wenn
man das nimmt was es gibt ich glaube
wenn es um fälligkeit geht weil wir uns
schnell auf eine neue zeit einstellen
müssen da muss man vielleicht auch von
der ein oder anderen spezifikation die
genauso für die deutsche bundeswehr sein
muss abrücken und sagen wir nehmen jetzt
ein system das das bewährt ist das
verbündete von uns haben wir müssen ihr
zusammenarbeiten also in einem einsatz
fall ist es sowieso ein nato verbund der
eingreift also lasst uns equipment
nehmen das ist immer das ist die frau
strack zimmermann hat als erster glaube
ich darauf aufmerksam gemacht los keine
deutschen entwicklungen das dauert dann
irgendwie itself wieder jahrzehnte
danach wollte ich sie eigentlich fragen
aber geben wir die frage noch einmal zu
frau lamprecht zurück bei die im einkauf
den sie da jetzt tätigen sind die
amerikaner zu allem bereit und werden
uns helfen die kürzeste die fristen zu
verkürzen fragezeichen werden wir
schneller eine wohlfeile gut
ausgestattete bundeswehr haben als 20 30
auf
jeden fall werden wir da unterstützung
bekommen aber auch eine f 35 steht nicht
irgendwo auf der halde und kann einfach
abgeholt werden um das jetzt mal so
einfach zu beschreiben sondern auch da
dauernd prozesse bis 2025 würde ich mal
sagen und dann muss daran ausgebildet
werden also dass die vorstellung dass
ein 35 oder 35 35 auf der halde stehen
und von uns nur abgenommen werden müssen
ich glaube die vertritt nicht nicht
irgendjemand
realistisch aber tatsächlich geht es
darum bei beschaffungen darüber hinaus
wir reden ja auch über ganz andere
probleme in der bundeswehr
beispielsweise dass wir keine
kompatiblen funkgeräte haben dass wir im
einsatz nicht mit anderen nationen uns
austauschen können das ist eine
situation die muss sich dringend und
schnellstmöglich ändern und da kann ich
dann beispielsweise auf markt verfügbare
produkte zurückgreifen genau das wird
der weg sein das wäre schon mal schauen
was gibt es ohne etwas zu entwickeln die
entwicklung von einem bundeswehr
rucksack beispielsweise selbst die gab
es für mich nicht nachvollziehbar wie
man auf diese idee kommt und damit muss
schluss sein deswegen markt
verfügbarkeit prüfen viel schneller sein
keine langwierigen prozesse antreten da
wo sie nicht sein müssen wir haben
rahmenverträge die sind geschlossen
waren aus purer finanznot weil man eben
pro jahr nicht mehr zur verfügung hatte
aber aus diesen rahmenverträgen kann ich
jetzt lieferungen vorziehen kann die
früher geraten das ist vereinbart da
sind wir im gespräch mit der industrie
deswegen es wird muss viel schneller
gehen dass geld allein das ist sehr viel
geld aber das reicht nicht sondern auch
die prozesse die beschaffungsprozesse
müssen schneller müssen effizienter
werden und das wird dann liegt die
gesamte runde und 5000 helme kommen uns
hoffentlich auch irgendwie nicht noch
mal über die lippen es sind ein paar
mehr geworden zum glück auch das müssten
wir das nächste mal müssten sie
vielleicht anders kommunizieren frau
lamprecht wie groß war diese fehler
würden sie denken
wenn sie einen brief bekommen in so
einer situation von der ukraine aus der
ukrainischen botschaft bitte helft uns
mit helmen dann mache ich als
verantwortliche verteidigen und die
ministerin folgen das ich frag in der
bundeswehr ab was könnt ihr was könnt
ihr sofort lieber in diesem brief renner
stand keine zahl keine zahl sondern
bitte unterstützt uns mit helmen und
dann haben wir sofort das geliefert was
wir sofort liefern konnten und das sind
diese 5000 helmer kunde und deswegen
wenn so eine anfrage kommt dann prüfen
wir weil wir unterstützen das
olaf scholz die 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr zur chefsache macht ist das
ein zeichen dafür dass der bundeswehr
nicht traut oder dass er ihnen nicht
traut
es ist ein zeichen dafür dass er großes
interesse an der landesrat der
bündnisverteidigung hat und was wäre es
denn für ein bundeskanzler wenn das
nicht so wäre also ich bin sehr froh
dass ich ein bundeskanzler habt ja daran
interesse hat manche ja in manchen
jahren war das anders
wir bedanken uns christine lambrecht war
das aus new york zugeschaltet sie machen
sich jetzt wieder auf den weg richtung
heimat einen guten abend oder besser
einen guten tag zu ihnen und wir sind in
der runde robin alexander nochmal bei
dem ganz kurzen blick auf die deutsche
wirtschaft die wird in bezug auf
verteidigung und rüstung und
rüstungsausgaben tatsächlich das
nachsehen haben das war sie nicht dafür
bin ich auch kein experte ich habe aber
den verdacht dass man sich um die
deutsche rüstungsindustrie keine sorgen
machen muss das ist der viertgrößte
rüstungsexporteur der welt also diese
leute waren mit krieg immer schon gut
verdient und werde das auch jetzt wieder
hinkriegen ich glaube was man noch mal
besprechen muss ist dass diese
fähigkeitslücken über die wir gesprochen
haben ein tolles deutsches war genau
jetzt fahre ich auch schon dieses länge
entstehen also dass die warum kann die
bundeswehr weiß nicht was sie dringen
können muss so das ist durch politische
entscheidungen entstanden also ein
beispiel jetzt soll für 20 milliarden
munition gekauft werden das ist keine
entwicklungsfragen sohn gab es das war
eine politische entscheidung oder dieser
f-35 und dem die ministerin keine
sprache der iss verhindert worden zu
kaufen die oppositions vorräte waren
leer seit 2011 also der f-35 den hätte
frau kramp karrenbauer sofort persönlich
aus amerika rübergeflogen und die spd
hat sich dagegen gewehrt oder die
berühmte entscheidung mit den drohnen
wir sehen doch jetzt wieder in diesem
ukraine krieg die drohnen sind
entscheidend die spd hat kurz vor der
bundestagswahl gesagt aber wir müssen
noch einmal gesellschaftlich über töten
mit joystick reden ich sage nicht dass
das eine blöde position ist aber wir
sollten uns ehrlich machen dass die
bundeswehr nicht fit ist ist nicht die
schuld der bundeswehr und auch nicht nur
der industrie sondern das waren
politische fehlentscheidung diesen fct
rische bei dann bin ich schon hochgradig
beunruhigt wenn die
verteidigungsminister sagt die
ausrüstung für ein paar hundert soldaten
die musste zusammengesucht werden also
jetzt muss man verteidigungsfähigkeit
deutschlands glaube ich nicht mehr
beschreiben würde das liegt auch daran
dass man über 20 jahre die bundeswehr
als finanziellen steinbruch für andere
haushalte gesehen hat wir keine kultur
der sicherheit in der bundeswehr hatten
die bundeswehr war lückenbüßer für
vieles und das ist wird jetzt
hoffentlich anders wir müssen nochmal
über gas und die us sanktionen reden
weil auch das ein wichtiges ergebnis und
ereignisse des heutigen tages war
trotzdem wollte ich von neubauer auch
noch mal nach diesen waffenlieferungen
fragen von 100 milliarden in die
bundeswehr waffenlieferungen aus
deutschland in diesen krieg damit die
ukraine für ihre freiheit kämpfen können
und hoffentlich für ein demokratisches
leben
sagen sie das ist wahnsinnig viel geld
und das darf man nur ausgeben wenn es
anderswo gespart wird oder sagen sie wir
haben da wirklich
fähigkeitslücken wir haben da wirklich
echte dinge
naja vielleicht seit kurzem bogen so
spannend für mich ja schon sehr skurril
ich bin 25 was waren die drei großen
erzählungen meiner kindheit ihr werdet
es mal besser haben es gibt keinen krieg
mehr in europa und merkel macht schon
das wurde mir erzählt dass wir jetzt
sitze ich hier und da bricht alles fällt
alles in sich zusammen die krisen
beschleunigen sich wir haben mit der
klimakrise angefangen dann kam die
partie medienkrieg da alles geht weiter
die klimakrise wartet hier auch nicht
wesentlich
und natürlich muss jetzt zu sagen müssen
wir ganz anders darüber nachdenken wie
wir eigentlich diesen krisen begegnen
können ohne eine einzige krise weiter zu
beschleunigen denn das können wir uns
überhaupt nicht mehr leisten
und dass wir jetzt natürlich über über
rüstung und über waffenexporte sprechen
jetzt auch ich glaube eine debatte in
dem ich mich so sagen die gesehen habe
wir sind in einem krieg ist eine
ausnahmesituation und natürlich hab ich
und ich glaube sehr sehr viele andere
menschen in diesem land auch ganz
mulmiges gefühl bei waffenexporten
grundsätzlich aber natürlich muss ich
die ukraine verteidigen können ich frag
mich an der stelle aber auch noch gerade
im gespräch mit verlangt recht wann
kommt denn eigentlich der punkt wo man
anerkennt dass wir nicht nur die ukraine
ausrüsten mit dem was wir haben sondern
auch putin also wir zahlen ja jeden tag
weiter damit putin seine armee weiter
ausstatten kann und zu sagen wir wir
sagen es ist nicht so als würden wir
eindeutig sagen die der ukraine helfen
sondern wir verlängern ja diesen krieg
ununterbrochen mit diesen unglaublichen
exporten und das macht mich schon ein
bisschen
ja und ich finde ich finde es krass wie
man so lange über waffenexporte sprechen
kann ohne ein einziges mal zu erwähnen
dass das nicht das einzige land ist
indem wir dass wir gerade in irgendeiner
art und weise aus starten in diesem
krieg wir sind damit im grunde sofort
auch bei den sanktionen und bei dem was
wir jetzt besprechen wollen um noch mal
auf die volten des heutigen tages zu
gucken
alarm an der deutschen energie front die
früh warnstufe ist ausgelöst ein
notfallplan soll die erdgasversorgung
sichern nach einem russischen
lieferstopp egal wann und wie mit
dramatischen konsequenzen
wir sind quasi kriegspartei als
wirtschafts kriegspartei und wir zahlen
auch einen preis der ist natürlich
nichts verglichen mit dem preis den
preis die ukrainer zahlen wir werden
dadurch ärmer werden
verwirrende signale aus moskau gab es
nur noch gegen rubel hieß es gestern
euros doch okay heute putins rubel
dekret verlässlichkeit sieht anders aus
die deutsche wirtschaft hochnervös
chemie steht am anfang aller
produktionsprozesse in deutschland das
heißt keine chemie heißt in der
konsequenz auch die lieferketten brechen
die produktionsketten brechen zusammen
das hat massive auswirkungen auf alle
branchen automobil auf bauindustrie auf
pharmaindustrie noch fließt das gas in
der notfall stufe entscheidet die
regierung wem es zuerst abgedreht wird
die bundesregierung noch mal eine frage
an luisa neubauer macht sich wahnsinnige
sorgen um den sozialen frieden in diesem
land und begründet sie warum sie nicht
schneller auch das russische gas
abdrehen möchte und die sanktionen
anderer länder da einsteigt
sorgen sie sich nicht um den sozialen
frieden also wenn ich das so sagen kann
hier ich finde es ehrlich gesagt ist
allerletzter frieden gegeneinander
auszuspielen und den sozialen frieden in
deutschland auf die andere seite zu
stellen und zu sagen ja und deswegen
können wir nicht viel zu sagen mit allem
was wir haben für den frieden in der
ukraine kämpfen oder uns dafür einsetzen
dass wir nicht unehrlich und wenn wir
darüber sprechen das ist belastung
deutschland gibt ja da müssen wir das
machen die wird es geben aber dann lass
uns doch konkret werden was ist genau
das problem wird es zu teuer für die
menschen ja das stimmt ist es für viele
bereits von jetzt und bezahlbar was
passiert da muss man da konkret helfen
das entlastungspaket was jetzt die
bundesregierung verabschiedet hat
beinhaltet unter anderem die fossile
subvention die das spritsparen
vergünstigt das trifft vor allem die
reichsten diesem land mit den größten
autos die am meisten fahren können und
in der regel seine frau leben haben sie
sich das zu leisten also wenn es darum
geht menschen zu entlasten baches gute
soziale politik und vernünftige soziale
ausgleichsmaßnahmen und dann können wir
darüber reden wie man das embargo
umsetzen kann wenn es eigentlich die
sorge ist dass wir mit der
chemieindustrie machen dann muss doch
auch ein minister in der lage sein sich
für die deutsch verstanden zu sagen
hallo wir müssen eine ernsthafte debatte
mit der chemieindustrie führen denn wir
haben hier große probleme wir wollen
aber rausfinden was wir wie schnell
machen können wir wollen hier nicht mit
sozusagen so populistischen sagen großen
rhetorischen den leuten angst davor
machen dass morgen die heizung ausgeht
dass wird sie ja nicht sondern wir
nehmen uns ernste sache an dieses
oberflächliche wir können es nicht wegen
dem sozialen frieden finde ich finde ich
demokratisch tragisch weil es jegliche
augenhöhe verpasst und es impliziert ja
auch dass es überhaupt keine möglichkeit
geben würden in bargum durchzusetzen und
da sind sich die experten über also
sagen einig wenn man das möchte geht
dass das kommt mit einem preis und damit
müssen uns beschäftigen und gleichzeitig
leute wir sind in einem angriffskrieg
also seit wann ist das sozusagen seit
wann es überhaupt eine option dass man
ohne einen preis für irgendwen da wieder
rauskommen und damit sind wir bei der
wirtschaft herum das ist jetzt gleich
ordentlicher strauß an fragen wie groß
das ist meine erste ist ihre besorgnis
für das was deutsche unternehmen
deutsche wirtschaft zu schultern hätte
wenn es tatsächlich schneller als jetzt
alle erwarten dieses gas embargo gibt
und zwar nicht durch uns sondern durch
ein problem die sorge ist sehr groß und
sie lässt sich nur unzureichend in geld
ausdrücken er ist nun mal aufpassen geld
allein schießt keine tore das buch das
war auch vorher in der diskussion schon
ein bisschen schwierig fand ich auch
hier gilt wenn es nur eine geldfrage wer
dann könnte man über manches diskutieren
aber wir haben auf die wissenschaftler
ab auch ein bisschen die berechnet haben
dass es durch leere im durchschnitt
gerechnet haben und diese durchschnitts
rechnung die habe ich verstanden ich
habe mit vielen der ökonomen inzwischen
auch gesprochen weil ich verstehen
wollte was bringt sie dahin wie habt ihr
gerechnet und ihnen auch erklärt warum
wir zu anderen schlussfolgerungen
gekommen weil die wir haben zwei sehr
grundlegende probleme mit dem thema aus
dem gas raus zu geben das eine ist die
vernetzung unserer wirtschaft wenn wir
über keramikindustrie reden dann denken
wir jetzt zuerst mal an tassen und
teller
zwei drittel der keramikindustrie ist
technische keramik das sind komponenten
die ganz lange ketten haben dass der
keramik welt körper geht in caramel
klagen
flugzeugtriebwerk baut keine flugzeuge
die keramik gelenkpfanne gibt luft lag
also wir haben ganz viele verletzungen
die zu quantifizieren in geld
auszudrücken das kann ich nicht aber sie
sind verdammt kompliziert der zweite
dimension ist physik das gasnetz kann
man sich vorstellen wie das wurzelwerk
eines baumes von einspeise stelle zu
allen möglichen verbraucher das ist
nicht darauf ausgelegt das formel ist
derjenige der an der listen wurzel sitzt
der irgendwo im thüringer wald eine
glashütte hat für den ist die frage der
priorisierung durch die netzagentur
unerheblich denn da kommt kein gas mehr
also wir müssen uns den realitäten
stellen
müssen wir uns den realitäten stellen
wenn putin und dem das gas abdreht ja
müssen wir
müssen wir es herbeiführen damaligen
ganz dicken vorsichtig aber nun jemand
deren in barkow vorschlägt schlägt das
ja vor weil es leicht oder
unkompliziertes sondern weil es richtig
und notwendig ist und weil wir jeden tag
in dem ist das nicht gibt ein
kriegsverbrecher weiter finanziert die
realität vor der wir stehen und das ist
dramatisch und es ist super auf wenn ich
das nie geht ja überhaupt niemand aber
sozusagen also was denn die alternative
das heißt die alternative ist zu sagen
wie alle werden mit diesem soziale
frieden argument dafür mit sozusagen
eine eingespannt weiter jeden tag
dutzende millionen euro an putin zu
schicken und vielleicht als eine
wichtige andere dimension wenn wir von
dem gas embargo zu sprechen auch der
bedarf also wieso ist denn die nachfrage
von energien in deutschland so heilig
wie sie darf man das nicht antasten
christian lindner stellt sich hin und
sagt erneuerbare energien sind jetzt
frei als energien ich frage mich wenn er
sich ins bett und sagt übrigens die
denken dass weitermachen natürlich jetzt
auch ein tempolimit für die freiheit das
wäre ja nur konsequent aber wir sind
auch eine lehrstelle kann man viel
machen mit einem tempolimit ersetzt man
sicherlich nicht die dimension um die
wir reden es sind jetzt 40 prozent
unseres gesamten gasverbrauchs dass wir
von putin bekommen ich wollte einmal
noch mal fragen herum bis die deutsche
wirtschaft das haben sie in einem
interview angedeutet höchst die deutsche
wirtschaft tatsächlich mit dieser
jetzigen lage auch ein bisschen für 20
jahre richtig satte gewinne die sie auch
mit und russland und über russland
gemacht hat friedrich merz sagt der
verstand das geld hat den verstand
gekauft bei politikern und
wirtschaftsführern die diskutieren sie
des untersees überlasse ich die vokabel
des büßten kirche und sagt ja wir haben
eine friedensdividende eingefahren das
ist ein extrem effiziente energieträger
übrigens auch ein sehr erhaben
effizienter das klimagas angehen wir
haben wirklich während hier haben in der
migration in den migrations paten ganz
bewusst gesagt wir gehen aus kohle raus
und halbieren den co2 ausstoß mancher
prozesse unter der annahme dass wir
genügend gas haben die zerg legt sich
gerade
lernen wir alle raus aber ein anfang
habe ich da muss ich wirklich
widersprechen
wir finanzieren mit dem import aus
russland wir finanzieren das system aber
wir finanzieren nicht diesen krieg habe
ich
menschen unterschiedlich wenn wir aber
nochmal der krise bitte sagen sie das
geht gar nicht dieses argument gibt es
ja weil wir überhaupt über das swift
abkommen und den das embargo gegenüber
den banken vermeiden dass das geld
unmittelbar jetzt für kriegs zahlungen
verwandt werden kann ihr argument es
liegt ja auch an deutschland das wir nur
sieben banken sperren und nicht 20
beziehungsweise wenn man alles
zusammenrechnet 300 russische banken und
das zweite ist unsere fraktion die cdu
csu hat der regierung ein angebot
gemacht nämlich das hat friedrich merz
auch sehr deutlich gemacht wir sind
bereit auf nord stream 1 zu verzichten
das hat einen hohen preis ich würde noch
weiter gehen das wissen sie aber ich
teile diesen diesen ansatz das ist
nämlich etwas wo wir auch der
öffentlichkeit zeigen und der
bevölkerung und auch der ukraine dass
wir bereit sind ein preis dafür zu
zahlen
sechs monate das hat ursprünglich herr
röttgen ins gespräch gebracht glaube ich
ihnen ein land viel weiter wir müssen
auf nord stream 1 verzichten wir können
das sicherlich einige monate machen aber
wir sehen ja quasi im gesicht von herrn
h blick welche mühe er sich gibt und wie
schwierig es ist aber jeden tag
finanzieren wir mit 700 millionen euro
russland und davon in deutschland 200
und die deutschen mit 300 und davon
fließen natürlich mittelbar russwurm
etliche gelder auch in die
staatsfinanzierung damit in die
bezahlung der streitkräfte und das
sollten wir öffentlich machen damit wir
auch in unserer bevölkerung klar machen
leute wenn wir den gürtel enger
schnallen ist das eine riesenaufgabe das
müssen wir sehr sorgfältig kommunizieren
das fehlt mir ein bisschen stolz die
frau bernburg macht es und das wäre
schon ein guter punkt klar zu machen wir
es kommt noch mehr auf uns zu und dann
ist auch die bevölkerung gewiss bereit
höhere spritkosten zu tragen und wir
müssen nur für die industrie ein ausweg
finden und so schnell wie möglich
verhandeln und ersatz finden ich sehe
also wenn wir sie in die wiese nicht hin
die an der arbeit für die er braucht
weder für seine soldaten noch für seinen
treibstoff heute genießen
also wir müssen uns da auch ehrlich
machen dass wir so schnell wie schön
ein weil ich finde dass erklärt das
argument natürlich ist es wahr dass die
panzer für diesen krieg schon lange
bezahlt worden sind aber dieses argument
wir zahlen unsere energie in euro oder
dollar das stimmt ja so nicht es war
vorher schon so dass zum beispiel die
gazprombank ausgenommen war von den
sanktionen und die sind angehalten 80
prozent der devisen umzutauschen in
rubel ist es ja kein wunder dass der
rubel kurs sich wieder so dramatisch
stabilisiert hat und wie unsere eigenen
sanktionen dadurch eigentlich
unterwandern dieser umtausch findet auch
jetzt statt natürlich wird putin rubel
zur verfügung haben und nur weil
vielleicht die panzer schon bezahlt sind
heißt das ja nicht dass wir nicht die
komplette infrastruktur bezahlen dass
wir nicht für putin leichter machen auch
die unterstützung seiner eigenen
bevölkerung weiter zu haben darum geht
es ja es geht ja darum durch die
sanktionen den druck auf putin zu
erhöhen und nicht
die illusion dass wir den krieg dadurch
beenden können die ist natürlich falsch
aber der druck auf putin würde natürlich
steigen wenn wir das dann aber
entschuldigt dann jetzt mal die frage an
die sicherheitsexperten wenn wir den
druck auf putin erhöhen ist das denn
eine garantie dafür dass er dann mit uns
verhandeln will also haben wir nicht
verstanden dass er wenn er sich an die
wand gedrängt fühlt eigentlich
gefährlicher wird also zum beispiel
gerade die verhandlungen istanbul es
gibt schon kleine fortschritte kleine
zugeständnisse russlands die russen
wollten eigentlich in belarus verhandeln
die ukraine haben istanbul vorgeschlagen
es ist dann jetzt istanbul geworden wir
sehen auch in der wortwahl
zugeständnisse und auch wenn ich glaube
das lag noch lange nicht so weit ist
wirklich hier zugeständnisse zu machen
glaube ich dass man mittlerweile schon
sieht wie schlecht die russische armee
vorankommt und es geht wirklich darum
druck und genau den druck auf putin zu
erhöhen robin alexander muss uns helfen
bei der interpretation dessen was heute
geschehen ist wladimir putin sagt auf
der einen seite es kann den europäern
möglich gemacht werden weiter in euro
und dollar zu zahlen auf der anderen
seite hatte ein dekret unterschrieben
das ist für jeden staat und
offensichtlich auch für die firmen
notwendig macht bei einer noch nicht
sanktionierten bank oder den zwei mit
denen auch viel zusammen arbeiten ein
zweites konto zu errichten ist das jetzt
nieder eine nächste finden und wird im
morgen dann tatsächlich schauen das gas
abzudrehen oder versucht er den
europäern da einen weg zu öffnen um
weiter geld zu bekommen ich glaube was
man da verstehen muss ist die leitenden
leute in der bundesregierung die
überweisen ja auch nicht gerne diese
summen gesehen ja auch diesen krieg also
werden wir das verhältnis schon gehört
die 80 millionen auf die frau lambrechts
und stolz waren insgesamt und die 300
millionen täglich für putin und ehrlich
gesagt dass er damit nichts anfangen
kann dafür ist er ziemlich hinterher
dass er das zeug weiter kriegt dann und
das glaube ich irgendwie keine sekunde
so und die bundesregierung würde
natürlich wenn putin das gas ab stellt
der bevölkerung erklären was machen wir
jetzt kommen harte zeiten aber hier ist
unser plan sie trauen sich nur nicht es
von sich aus abzustellen weil sie denken
dann haben sie demonstration vom
wirtschaftsministerium kanzleramt und
wenn putin es ab stellt haben sie vor
der russischen botschaft das ist eine
interessante these sie sagen es macht
einen unterschied ob der boykott über
uns
kommt von moskauer seite oder ob es die
bundesregierung selber aussprechen es
gibt leute die bundesregierung die sagen
wir hatten schon gedacht nur die waffen
liefern stellte ab dann haben wir
gedacht also die zentralbank
abgeschnitten haben stellt er von sich
aus ab weil er so zornig ist ja so das
tut er erkennt man nicht weil er unsere
politische lage einschätzt und jetzt
kann man mit frau neubauer bedauern dass
unsere politiker nicht die kraft haben
sich jetzt schon vor die bevölkerung zu
stellen und zu sagen diesen krieg wollen
wir nicht finanzieren
wir haben jetzt anderen plan aber in dem
moment wie putin das tut wird er das
machen und genau darum geht dass ich
mein putin ruf bei scholz an bittet um
das gespräch
und weil es immer anders scholz ist
vorher festgelegt worden schon selber
hat am anfang ganz anders geredet er hat
gesagt ich glaube die verträge so lange
wie die überblicken sind in euro und
robert habeck hat deutlich gesagt wir
zahlen nicht in rubel und hat den rest
von g7 darauf verpflichtet und jetzt
versucht putin eine brücke zu bauen also
zahl in euro und meine bank klammer auf
haben wir schon gehört die nicht auf der
sanktionsliste steht die konvertiert das
dann so die frage ist ob
sich der kanzler darauf einlässt
ob dieses modell haltbar ist aber dass
wir uns da in ein moralisch ganz
schwieriges fahrwasser weil man sagt
immer wie halten wir das durch wenn das
gas nicht mehr kommen wie halten wir es
denn durch werden der krieg weiter gehen
das muss doch gar nicht am ende sein was
machen wir denn die amerikaner warnen
dass der chemie waffen einsatz für die
russen eine option ist und bisher sind
viele warnung der amerikaner in diesem
krieg wahr geworden wenn das passiert
ein chemiewaffen einsatz in einer
großstadt 30.000 tote von wir weiter
zeiten wollen wir dass unser bevölkerung
erklären also ego
das nur auf geld zu verkürzen auch das
muss bei uns passieren wird das ist zu
kurz gesprungen einige sorgen könnten es
sind helfen nicht nur tempolimits es ist
eine rezession
es ist ein wirklich abbrechen unserer
industriellen netzwerke und das darf man
nicht auch das ist ehrlichkeit der
bevölkerung gegenüber das nochmal jetzt
nicht umrechnen und sagen das kostet pro
kopf 800 euro oder so was das müssen wir
halt schultern wir regen über eine ganz
andere art des zusammenrechnung unserer
industrie die übrigens auf die wir ganz
stolz waren das die uns durch corona
durch getragen habe während am grübeln
die sanktionen dürfen uns nicht mehr
schaden als dem aggressor wie es geht ja
aber an dem augenblick darum dass man
den krieg beendet oder zumindest dazu
beiträgt dass der krieg beendet wird das
kosten gibt natürlich die frage ist
irgendwer wird sie tragen müssen und wir
sind wir stehen wir sprechen die ganze
von europäischen werten band ist ein
moment wo wir sagen wir stehen wirklich
hinter den europäischen werten und wir
tragen dass wir neben last von den
schultern und vielleicht noch einmal sie
bezogen ja es gibt es wird sagen ganz
ganz schwierige momente geben da muss
man sich hinter muss den leuten das
erklären demonstrationen gibt es ja
schon heute von den leuten die das 1
fordern die mehrheit in der bevölkerung
gesagt sie befürwortet so ein embargo
aber wie gesagt um noch einmal kurz den
blick zu weiten ich frag mich wo bleiben
denn wirklich alle gemeinsam bemühen
erst mal den bedarf so weit runter zu
fahren wie man ihn irgendwie runter da
hast du wirklich nicht nur einfach
hinzustellen zu sagen leute bitten
sondern vorzulegen das sind nur das ist
die strategie wir machen es sichtbar wir
gehen eine behörden vor wir machen als
in den ministerien gerechnet wirklich
mal durchgekommen wir da wohl erstmal
sparen
und das jetzt gemerkt habt der jetzt
noch nicht was ihm spaß weil er seine
energie rechnung für seine aussagen muss
oder seine rechnungen an der tankstelle
zahlen muss also wer das noch nicht
gemacht hat mehr mehr mehr mehr
lenkungswirkung braucht du bist
wahrscheinlich nicht zu helfen also die
leute die die studien zeigen jetzt zum
beispiel
das fahrverhalten anguckt viele leute
fahren gerade weniger auto weniger
werden nicht weniger auto fährt sind die
mit den größten autos die am schnellsten
waren da müssen wir uns stellen zunächst
meisten geld haben und einmal um den
bogen bitte zu sparen denn das ist doch
das entscheidende hier ist geht ja
irgendwann anders wir werden nicht immer
in diesen fossilen abhängigkeiten sein
müssen und was jetzt kommt die
bemühungen sei es mit dem aufrüsten und
sei es mit dem wagners worten sei es mit
der industrie muss doch begleitet werden
mit einem radikalen um chance habe ich
am eigenen der sendung schon gesagt denn
autokraten gibt es viele auf der welt
und von einer fachjury abhängigkeit in
die andere zu kommen ist keine option
und gas übrigens für die zukunft
werden wir bestimmt noch ein paar sachen
zu machen ich muss hier ganz schnell
einen punkt machen und wurde es auch
sofort darf mich ganz herzlich bedanken
für die debatte heute markus lanz hat
unter anderem angesprochen ist er schon
in den vizekanzler zu gast robert habeck
ist bei ihnen wie
wenn sie mögen nächsten donnerstag wie
der gleiche stelle gleiche welle kommen
sie gut durch diesen abend und bis nicht
das dankeschön
[Musik]